so everybody welcome to our January PI
data and Arbor Meetup I'm Rose Butler
I'm one of the co-organizers
of Ann Arbor payday to meet up along
with Sean and Ben who you met downstairs
probably if you have not met them before
so I just want to acknowledge our
sponsors so numb focus which sponsors
the meetup TD Ameritrade which sponsors
this beautiful space and midis which who
provides the food so a couple of
important points we have emergency exits
both the way you came and through this
way feel free to provide feedback to the
organizers we have a Twitter and email
and you can talk to any of us afterwards
our github is here slides are usually
there okay this is a new line and we are
in a lovely lovely borrowed space so
please clean up after yourself so some
notes about Q&A after afterwards so I'm
unless quick hold your questions until
the end please freeze your question in
the form of a question try to keep
questions to 30 seconds or less avoid
long statements or monologues again
phrase your question and the form of a
question and there will be time for open
discussion after the Q&A with the
speaker and with everyone else so keep
that in mind so now I'm going to read
the PI data Code of Conduct
so PI data is dedicated to providing a
harassment free meeting experience for
everyone
regardless of gender sexual orientation
gender identity and expression
disability physical appearance body size
race religion or experience we do not
tolerate harassment of meeting
participants in any form all
communication should be appropriate for
a professional audience including people
of many different backgrounds and levels
of experience sexual language and
imagery is not appropriate for any of
our meetup events be kind to others do
not insult or put down other attendees
behave professionally remember that
harassment and sexist racist or
exclusionary jokes are not appropriate
for pi data attendees vital violating
these rules may be asked to leave the
meetup at the sole discretion of the
meetup organizers thank you for helping
make this a welcoming friendly event for
all so we're gonna do a quick icebreaker
so Eric our speaker gave us a great
icebreaker so turn to the person next to
you someone you don't know preferably
introduce yourself and then you get to
discuss what you think the best
breakfast in Ann Arbor is particularly
for a weekday morning like tomorrow
morning when our speaker will be still
here so so we'll give you a little bit
of time and then we'll call you back
together but best breakfast in Ann Arbor
go so hopefully we've sold it we know
the best breakfast in Ann Arbor and if
you have suggestions feel free to talk
to Eric afterwards and make sure that he
knows what you think the best breakfast
in Ann Arbor is exactly okay so this
month in data science open source
directions is a podcast hosted by Quon
site so they highlight different open
source projects and especially in data
data science base open source projects
in their podcast so go ahead and check
that out our next event next month will
be Amy Hemet er and she will be talking
about the summarization of news articles
using text ranked so we're excited about
that Amy so that'll be February 12th
another Wednesday and same place so we
are seeking that week but we wanted to
advertise that they are seeking
panelists for a discussion after a movie
screening at the Mission
Theatre on debugging the gender gap so
it sounds like they prefer more than
five years of experience in tech or
software engineering particularly
they're looking for a diverse panel if
you have questions or interests feel
free to email brooke Wolford here it is
during our March PI data event but I'm
sure it would be you would be a great
contributor to that event and yeah any
community announcements so for those who
let me let me explain first so so for
those who have not been to PI data
before which there are a fair number of
you today so we have this opportunity to
do community announcements for folks who
are looking for work for folks who have
work who folks who want to talk about
you know interesting packages they've
released or other things so this is your
opportunity to make an announcement and
folks can talk to you afterwards so
main topic speaker that means it's about
a 45 minute or so
to reach out to the organizer why great
thanks Amy
and over Detroit out
talk about economy
data scientist operations research
stinks so I also have a job announcement
my name is Craig Stevenson I work at a
company called interactive as the data
scientist on our data team we are a
growing IOT company with kind of a deep
technical play and that we produce a
battery list sensor to monitor various
industrial applications and we're also
kind of under undertaking more recent
developments to vastly improve our data
management and architecture practices
both to facilitate more quickly
answering business questions driving
insights and also furthering development
on our early failure detection
algorithms that's one of the big like
business values that we provide to our
customers
another neat thing about our data team
is the culture we're trying to promote
is something we're calling full stack
ownership so we're very purposefully
learning the lines between scientists
and engineer we want folks who are
interested in whether we conceptualizing
problems and doing exploratory analysis
but also taking those two production
heisting or deploying to production
we're hiring for Angelo
[Music]
create any other announcements great
[Music]
all right thank you everyone so now Eric
is a data scientist at the Novartis
Institute's for biomedical research
where he conducts research on machine
learning algorithms and their
application to early drug discovery
programs and builds machine learning
systems in support of bench science
he received his idea from MIT in 2017 in
the department of biological engineering
studying influenza evolution and ecology
at a global scale and was an insight
health data fellow where he built a flu
sequence evolution forecaster as his
project
he's also an open-source software
developer and community educator and I'm
not going to read his website but I'm
sure he will
so welcome Eric first off I want to say
I'm very honored to be here because I
heard stories of how there were
individuals who either had something at
8 p.m. and decided to like stay on just
to be able to catch it there are other
individuals who drove like 53 minutes
from another town just to make it here
so on my hand yeah it feels like
pressures on but on the other hand it
also feels great because like i i've
been a coastal person for most of my
life and so like i've lived on the two
coasts of North America Canada and
United States and I lived in Singapore
for a long time and I rarely come to a
landlocked area a part of a part of town
part of the country and so no I'm used
to like this coastal buzz of like all
the latest ideas which I know is like
there are less barriers now but it today
for me it's very eye-opening just to see
that the community out here and how
vibrant it is so for me it's an honor
and I think I have to also say Sean's a
great guy according to some things that
he says don't listen to Sean's a great
guy and I'm glad that I'm able to be
here okay so today when I was thinking
about brainstorming a little bit over
what might be a value to deliver to the
PI data community here I was thinking
mostly along the lines
of what's a valuable practice that we
might want to encourage but is under
under not done very often and so the
practice that I decided to talk a little
bit about is testing it's a very simple
easy to get started topic but we don't
talk about about we don't talk about it
very often and at least amongst peers
who are in other firms who work at other
places we don't I I don't see I don't
hear much from them about the practice
of writing tests as a data scientist
okay so I'm gonna flash the slides up
for the next 10 seconds if you would
like to get a copy of the slides you
actually can just scan the QR code with
your iPhone camera and you'll get it
otherwise you can read the miniscule
text at the bottom it's testing for data
scientists at the bottom alright and you
will have I think the CI system has
finished building the slides and so it's
up there ready for the latest version
that I'm presenting should be up there
as well I don't mind questions during
the talk but I will adhere to the rules
set down so please keep the questions
short but feel free to interrupt me any
time in between and also if you end up
like browsing through your phone during
the talk I'm just going to assume you're
looking at the slides on your phone ok
cool
so just a little bit about myself and
where I work before I move on I work for
the Novartis Institute for biomedical
research as Rose mentioned it's a lot of
machine learning it's a lot of machine
learning work I also happen to just do
on one project happen to play every
single role possible so software
engineer data engineer CI system quality
QA testing everything it it revealed for
me why I know I it revealed for me a lot
of deficiencies in knowledge let's just
put it that way I know some stuff about
software I know some stuff about testing
but really the core expertise that I
know that I'm competent in is
taking a problem defining it taking the
problem to completion and then
delivering the prototype and then maybe
working with others no no no offense
against I actually really love the fact
you guys want full ownership of the
whole step because a lot of projects get
lost on the throw over to software
engineering or throw over to to
production it's just I also know my
limitations and and that's something I
need to I need to learn and thankfully
being dropped into the deep end gives
you that learning opportunity I got into
the back to MIT through the back door
and walked out through the front if you
are ever curious about how that worked
out I can talk about it I'll just take
it like walking out through the front
door is a good one and finally I like
Python it's the primary it's the first
programming language that I really
delved deeply into and found that it was
friendly to use community was friendly
packages ecosystem very rich lets me do
a lot of stuff in few lines of code so
and a lot of people give back as well
so I think it's a it's a great community
I also have a lot of friends who use are
my manager uses our we have a good
relationship leave it there okay so
first off I have a question to pose to
you how many of you would identify
identify as a data scientist of some
kind statisticians included I don't want
to exclude you all because I believe
your works fundamentally very similar so
then how many of you write code more
than 50 of those who've raised their
hand
how many write code in a programming
language more than 50% of time okay and
how many of you write tests for code of
those who had their right hands raised
okay
so not a lot not a lot and so this
actually does confirm that my talk today
has a purpose and I'm not just speaking
to the preaching to the choir okay so
for those who choose not to write tests
what are the reasons and I want to be
completely non-judgmental here and I
really mean it um what are your reasons
for not writing tests could we have a
few volunteers first and then second
time okay big one
[Music]
not sure how to get started yep okay
got it the code is not the deliverable
okay cool cool stuff and then right
behind you one time code exactly good
back there okay yeah so sometimes it's a
lack of knowledge and that that same
same thing for me yep
they're getting to an answer and the
answers correct there's no reason to
test
and we as data people can fall into the
same trap yeah yeah absolutely now that
that was very frank and I again don't
want to be judgmental I have fallen into
that trap to myself so yes cool there's
like there's a there's there's just that
try that other neural network and like
forget about that test it's like not not
so important like that's interesting and
then of course now if that was one time
code
I'm not bitten in the butt later but if
that was not one time code that I needed
to write a test for well good luck to me
and for those who do write tests can I
ask what are your reasons
mm-hmm okay so you've come to depend on
it
and you need to know that you you also
can plausibly forecast that you'll need
to modify it yeah okay cool
and I saw a few hands there and then
we'll go to the right hand side after
Bradley yes
developer and use their own school
yep
okay okay and I saw another hand to the
left
it's a requirement so that someone above
said you have to do it so you do it
gotcha
the right there you want a save time
could you elaborate right
you might move slower mm-hmm
gotcha that's right I totally agree and
back there at last point intellectual
property rights can that that is
actually the first time I've heard this
reason can you elaborate on that
like for instance there there is an
algorithm out there that understands
what the green customer what they want
tested
okay okay okay
we'll make two exceptions I saw two more
hands yeah absolutely and yes yes
absolutely you need to well it also
relates to having confidence about what
what you're doing and that you can have
confidence that your program or your
code handles edge cases correctly yes
absolutely
okay so apart from IP all the other
reasons are valid reasons that I've
heard before and what I hope happens is
that in the discussion afterwards those
of you who haven't written code for
maybe not the best reasons do find
others who who who write sorry those who
don't write tests for maybe not the best
reasons find those who do and also at
the same time those who you who know the
ecosystem for testing in Python I'm
gonna allude to it later but give a talk
at PI data and Arbor look for Shawn and
he will sign you up to be a speaker all
right is that correct absolutely correct
okay great
cool so today I want to I want to convey
a few points namely if you are
self-identified sales data scientist who
is part of the broader data science
community and a big portion of your role
is in delivering something that involves
code to another team then investing in
writing tests today will bring you all
of the benefits that we discussed about
just now namely you'll save time later
on you'll decrease team frustration and
you'll increase team productivity and
when I say testing I really don't mean
this only in the sense of only testing I
actually mean this as a broader point
with respect to other software
engineering skills now I'm not expecting
that every data scientists in every
single project becomes you know writes
the most seasoned software engineered
code know what I'm trying to convey is
if we apply some basic software
engineering ideas like writing modular
functions that have limited scope like
writing tests and also writing Docs how
many of you write Docs not very many I
am guilty of that myself
I don't really write I don't really
write Docs on some occasions but if we
do adopt these practices we reap all of
these same three benefits and so today
I'm just gonna focus on testing okay so
to convey the message I'm actually going
to tell you two projects tell about two
projects that I worked on one is a hobby
project the other is a project at work
alright and the first one is how the use
of automated testing tools in Python
allowed me to reveal weak spots in my
code so before I could even think of the
weak spots automated testing tools
revealed them for me and so then that
gave me a lot of confidence in you know
building what I wanted to build the
second one is actually how writing tests
for my code as well as for data
automated sorry greatly accelerated a
lot of data analysis workflow downstream
because we had great confidence in what
we had to borrow the thing that Kyle
works on great expectations I had
perfect expectations about what I was in
what I was what data I was using okay
and so this is a I want to use these two
stories to convey those points so let's
start with my hobby project it's a
project in which I had been hacking on
since grad school and in this project
the goal is given protein sequence
predict drug resistance value so your
data sort of just looks like that
now I was interested in this problem in
grad school mostly because I was
interested in this phenotype genotype
phenotype problem given a genotype of a
vice
I predict a relevant clinically relevant
phenotype for those of you who want to
try to improve upon this I I don't want
to discourage you from trying but do
know that you probably won't make any
money out of it because there are
commercial systems for this so this is
really a good project to get into
machine learning and if you're in the
Biosciences machine learning in the
Biosciences or life sciences this is a
great project to attempt but don't have
any expectations that you'll make money
so we get data that looks something like
this I got protein sequence and I want
to predict a number it's as simple as
that there's nothing really complicated
okay so you can imagine it's a protein
sequence and machine learning algorithms
don't really take in strings do you have
to do some feature ization of the
sequence you have to convert that long
string into a vector and do it for every
single sample that you have so you know
we might write three functions and I'm
just I'm just going to give you the
rough architecture by the code it's
really I got a file I read in the
protein sequence from the file
I then feature eyes the sequence and
return the features and then I take
those features and load it into a pass
them into a second learn model and then
I get back a column vector of numbers we
okay with that so far so good okay so
this is sort of your very
run-of-the-mill
standard kind of supervised machine
learning project question to the crowd
now what have we assumed here in this
function that you think might plausibly
you need to be tested give it a moment
actually talk with your neighbors
another neighbor that you didn't
socialize with over this for about a
minute or so think about it and talk
about
okie Dokes alright let's gather back I
wanted to ask if anybody had ideas about
things that we're assuming for the first
function the one that I'm highlighting
up here what might we have assumed in
this function okay that you can find the
file cool there the correct format okay
anything else oh yeah okay cool very
good so there are a lot of assumptions
that you can see are happening in this
first function and those are all valid
what about the second function what part
of me okay right anything else
ah okay very good is the is the what do
you call that the the alphabet correct
anything else okay okay anything else
we're assuming
oh it's numbers my my bad sorry I should
I should have numeric yep okay all right
we're gonna move on how about that final
one what have we assumed here okay yep
anything else yep yeah okay anything
else valid point yes okay yep that's
right so especially when we're going
into a production system that's
something we want to think about back
there yes that as well okay and final
one back there
yes okay cool very good so as I'm
discovering slowly everybody here does
have the instinct we all do actually do
have these instincts so my my hypothesis
which I'm going to throw out is that
most of us don't write tests because we
are lacking time I think that's the
primary reason and the other is that we
we know we don't depend on it but then
the primary one is primary drivers for
work we don't we don't have time but
anyways let's come back to what we want
to test so in this particular example
I'm gonna focus mostly on the last two
functions right and it's partly because
of time partly because it's the easiest
to cut sort of grok all right so part of
me sorry to grass okay so first off
let's write a test for future eyes now
for those of you who are not familiar
with the testing machinery in the Python
world there's a package called PI test
and it lets you write functions that are
decorative of your tests so in order to
test the function feature eyes you would
import the function feature eyes from
wherever your library is then you would
write a function that calls that is
called test underscore some informative
name and inside there you place all of
your tests effectively what PI test is
doing is eliminating away a lot of the
boilerplate code that you might
alternatively write if you were to use
the built-in unit test framework now if
you're in this scenario where you can't
install packages use the unit test
framework if you're in a scenario where
you can I would strongly recommend that
you use the PI test framework for
testing because it provides a lot a lot
of conveniences and it also has a rich
ecosystem of extensions that I'm not
going to talk about today but I want to
keep you keeps your keep your appetites
wedded okay so how would we write it we
might say let's input something that is
a known valid example so let's take a
known HIV protein protease sequence
stick it inside here pass it
feats and then assert some properties of
that of that of the output okay and so
that's something that we might choose to
do we can also do a test for the
function predict okay in this case I've
only chosen to do a simple execution
test or you know just run the code kind
of a test the this is if you are in a
hurry this is this example pay example
based execution test is by far the
simplest example that you simplest test
that you can write you actually if you
are testing in interactively in a
Jupiter notebook you are doing execution
tests all the time does that make sense
so if you do that just copy the pace
copy and paste that block of code into a
test and execute it unless of course it
takes a long time to run but if if
nothing else this is the bare minimum so
I sort of hinted are we done with this
function then with this test clearly not
okay so as some of you mentioned the
input to the machine learning model is
an array or a matrix that is of width
five times the length of the protein
sequence okay so focusing on just this
one particular problem if I passed in a
sequence that was less than the the
sequence length that the model was
trained on I'm gonna get something
that's less than five times the length
of that HIV protease in the case of HIV
protease which is what this one's for
it's always 495 long vectors so I pass
in something because it's 99 amino acids
long if I pass in something that's 98
I'm gonna get an invalid input by
passing something that's a hundred I'm
still going to get an invalid input so
in order for the model to work I need to
ensure that my input to the model is
nineteen is 495 is a 495 long vector
I also therefore need to make sure that
the input to the feature i's function is
a 99 long string at the minimum and I
deliberately phrase it that way
because in the feature i's function you
can also have invalid inputs there are
as someone mentioned at the back invalid
amino acid letters O is not a letter in
the amino acid alphabet and so if I were
to pass in a string that has letter O it
should crash the program right so first
off if the user inputs a string for this
project if a user inputs a string that's
not 99 letters long the program should
crash and if a user inputs a string with
invalid characters something that's not
drawn from the 26 sorry 22 defined
letters for the amino acid alphabet or
24 I can't remember it's one of the two
there there are ambiguous characters
that are allowed and there's a special
asterisk character that is also allowed
if you're not amongst the set of
characters the program should also crash
right so let's try first by making the
code a little bit more robust okay so
first off we can say we can we can
declare a test that looks something like
this first off I first declare what the
acceptable letters here in this case I'm
deliberately omitting the asterisk
because I don't expect it to be present
we then take even though it is one of
the valid characters I'm not expecting
I'm designing the program not to not to
just ignore it we have the feature eyes
function and we can do a few checks
because we know this feature eyes
function is something that the machine
learning model depends on we therefore
bacon some checks hard checks over here
the length of the sequence must be 99
long and the set of characters that are
present inside the sequence must be a
subset of the acceptable characters and
then and only then do we do stuff to
future eyes okay
so then once we have this we can
actually make the test more robust as
well and so how would we do this
this is where I'm gonna introduce a few
concepts simultaneously so firstly you
can use PI tests to check that a program
errors out correctly right you can use
PI tests to check that a program errors
out correctly and the way that you do
that is to use this with PI test raises
syntax which allows you to say as which
allows you to declare I expect that
feature izing this sequence if the
sequence is not 90 line long to raise a
value error which I had previously
declined declared in the function the
second thing that I'm going to introduce
here is that you can actually use a
generator an automatic generator of test
examples that comes from the library
hypothesis and how many of you have
heard of hypothesis before it's a very
very good library for generating all
sorts of test data that you might want
to pass into your test functions okay
you can generate the strength you can
generate all the Python primitives so
strings lists of stuff tuples of stuffs
dictionaries of stuff nested data
structures that's all possible guess
what I also found out you can generate
numpy arrays you can also generate
pandas data frames which is amazing
right if you think about it I can
declare what data are supposed to look
like in my data frame and make sure that
the functions that operate on data
frames operate exactly as I want so I
can say use using pipe using hypothesis
and it's compatible sorry and it's
decorators that are compatible with PI
test I can declare that this function
should be given as part of the sequence
argument text that is drawn from the
acceptable letters alphabet and I'll
just for convenience hard code stuff
that are you know within the correct
bounds or most expected bounds okay and
so with this simple syntax that I can
start to declare how I want what kind of
data I want passed in into this function
to test it game
so you'll notice I deliberately uh I'll
get there I I ignored the invalid
character example for the time being but
you would use the exact same thing
except in this case replace the alphabet
with something that comes from in the
full suite of characters okay so you can
generate all of these examples very very
quickly in an automatic fashion it is
generating random inputs but oh sorry so
I think I misunderstood the question
your question is if I had two arguments
and two things that I wanted to pass in
right then would would we have would
they be considered independent and
therefore generated combinatorially or
or is it yes
it is the ladder yep so you don't you
don't necessarily have to cover the full
parameter space okay yes it is part of
the Python decorator syntax so the given
function modifies this function into
some other magic stuff but then you know
it reads well so you you're saying this
function should be given a certain set
of stuff John I think this is this is a
little bit out of my realm of current
knowledge but I think it is possible to
make them deterministic one thing that
hypothesis does is it intentionally
shrinks your examples to find examples
that break your code minimal examples
that break your code okay and I'm sort
of letting the conclusion out of the bag
everything that I'm going to talk
through over here is the ideal way to
discover to write your tests in reality
I use hypothesis to brute-force my way
to finding all the edge cases that I
never would have thought of because I'm
too lazy to think of them right and so
hypothesis will find them and it makes
me much more clearer about the code that
I write okay so we're now with that one
function better tested in a little bit
of a better position write that function
now has become something reliable
question yes no problem
yes
hypothesis has a default I think of a
few hundred examples that it will
generate so it's it's doing a lot of
stuff for you and in some respects you
can think about the old way of testing
where we have an example based execution
to example based test is being like
automatic manual testing I have to
declare certain types of certain
examples right that's automatic manual
testing so in if you watch the tutorials
at PyCon on one of them being escape
auto manual testing with hypothesis by
Zack had field
I forgot his surname but he's from
Australia he's got a conjugated surname
and so I can't remember at this moment
but Zack is the guy who one of the
people who maintains the hypothesis
library and he has a full-on tutorial
about that so I would strongly recommend
that you check it out okay
I think it's I think it's for future me
to be able to read it more than anything
else and I'm I mostly write code
defensively against future amnesia
that's that's how I write my code so
it's got to be easy to read okay so
we're in a little bit of a better
position the function as it stands
defends against unexpected inputs so we
have some defensive programming
happening the tests will help us catch
breaking changes and if you hand this
over to your engineers who are going to
do take things into production or if you
hand this to your future self six months
while you're taking it into production
then you're going to thank yourself or
your engineers are going to thank you
for writing robust code okay so I know
it is not not every team will have the
opportunity to take the thing to
production not every project will end up
like that but if you do it if you do it
for the projects that you know are going
to go to production then you've written
robust code for production purposes if
you try to do it to the best of your
ability on projects that are not in
production you have gained practice and
experience writing better and better and
better tests okay so that's that's my
word of encouragement for this little
bit here so like I mentioned just now I
actually use hypothesis two instead
brute-force my way to all of the invalid
inputs found all the invalid inputs made
the code more robust and then continued
continued iteratively
so you can use hypothesis both as a
library for just brute-force testing but
also for figuring out where the moat you
where your most obvious bugs might occur
okay so it's a it's a great library
writing tests in short also helps you
catch catch bugs cool
now the other story that I want to talk
about comes from my work work which is
the development of a protein engineering
platform at work we're doing enzyme
evolution I
and part of the three-person computation
informatics team that is supporting this
platform development and so in this
protein engineering platform we're
writing lots of code but it's a
relatively simple code base there's lots
of like independent utilities that we
have to write with some function sharing
and because I already did talk about
testing functions I'm actually not going
to talk about that in this example I'm
going to focus on data I'm going to talk
about like writing tests for your data
and I think it's important okay so our
data because we are in the development
phase of the platform and we're
developing assays the assays will change
from enzyme to enzyme where we're
therefore faced with this complex
evolving data sort of requirements right
I can set up a database for one enzyme
I'm probably going to have to ditch that
database if we have a new enzyme to load
data unless I structure things correctly
so basically as the platform gets built
out there's a lot of things that are
evolving sometimes as scientists will
say oh yeah this is the way we want to
calculate it and then three weeks later
we realize ah that really wasn't the way
we should like calculate the activity of
the enzyme we need to use a different we
need to use a different math equation so
the output that we're interested in
changes underneath us okay so that's how
these data requirements change and we we
do try to normalize the data base as far
as possible to the best that our tiny
little data scientist brains can
understand what database admins do but
yeah it's it's complex and we found
ourselves in this place where to get to
the place where we wanted like just the
data that we wanted like human readable
easily possible we have to do all these
crazy joins okay it was not fun how many
of you have maintained 30 lines sequel
joins to create your database views yeah
and when things change you have to run
back up the chain like if something
really way upstream changes you have to
propagate them slowly down to the final
view he was not fun so what we ended up
deciding was we're gonna ditch all of
our views because we're not gonna do
this we made some intentional choices
because we're not going to do this
database management thing long term I
t's going to help us for the development
phase we'll just like cache the raw data
and like use pandas to do our joins and
define all of our joins in pandas code
rather than worry about sequel joins and
maintaining things and wrestling for
hours each time to update update the
joints right okay so that's what we
ended up doing so yeah if you update and
maintain a 30 line sequel view you end
up with this face pretty often so
instead caching pandas dataframes was
the right thing to do sorry I have liked
these puns I really like okay so the
problem here the problem here is that if
you think if you work with Python
packages you know how important the API
is there's a reason why I have a slight
distaste for the tensor packages that
have been developed because they don't
respect the numpy api which is extremely
idiomatic likewise I've had friends
colleagues ex colleagues who in their
other jobs encountered data analysts who
really nearly changed the schema names
going from capital letter to the
lowercase and the likes and I said Andy
you got to write tests for your data man
and that's when this really started
showing up in as like a real consequence
that someone might have to deal with
because all all of Andy's production
systems were broken by a capitalization
change so yeah your schema is the API to
the data now we can have debates about
whether you want to access the schema
directly or you want to have like API
access data access layers or not that's
a choice you make but then whatever it
is your schema is the data API it has
got to be stable or if changes that
happen they have to be caught as early
as possible before anything in
production fails
so so yeah if the schema changes even
slightly we want to know this ASAP so
how do you then write tests for data I'm
gonna give you one example this is not
by by means by no means ever the most
authoritative example but if you really
need to get up really quickly without
using highly engineered frameworks or
libraries to do it and you just need to
have something quick and dirty here's
how you can do it so you might want to
test some things you want to check that
your column names are correct sometimes
you might want to also check that your
row indices follow some order you want
to check your column data types you want
to check that what you expect to not
have any null values are actually not
know yeah you want to check that the
bounds of your data are are correct you
don't want to have if something is
supposed to range from zero to 200 and
you get a - 999 who was that data
analyst - yes
okay can you think of any more beyond
what these examples that I've listed yep
okay so you want to make sure that your
distributions if your predictions depend
on a particular distribution of data
that distribution of data should remain
the same okay anything else okay you
want to make sure that there are no
duplicates where there are not supposed
to be any duplicates okay anything else
are the syntax of your queries now that
assumes we use sequel but yes yes
absolutely yes when you do what you call
that in sequel and you call those like
foreign key referencing right yeah you
want to make sure that that's all
correct as well anything else if not I
think we pretty much covered it so an
example of a very lightweight example of
how you can get tests written for your
data is to do something like this you
you query your data and you explicitly
write your tests that way okay that's
one way of getting up to speed now Kyle
here works on great expectations and I
we deleted the slide but I still wanted
to mention it like the only thing that
has stopped me from using great
expectations at work is time which is
exactly the same reasons why same reason
why some of us don't write test time and
that's the that if you look through how
great expectations work it's a little
bit complex in getting set up but there
are easy entry points into it you can
you can use that to to declare some of
these tests in much more readable
declaration has these test functions
that go assert or expect that this
column is not null or something like
that okay it's got this very nice syntax
that between plain English Lang in plain
English function names tells you what
you're expecting about your data which
is I think where the name of the package
comes from right great expectations some
novels there we go so yes so it is
another package to check out okay now I
wanted to talk a little bit then about
how tests accelerated our workflow okay
we use data caching so we cached like
once a week we pull down the latest data
onto our local machine because we know
we're not going to maintain that
database long term but we still need to
use it to prove it
it's okay we cache the data we write
some tests for the data if you remember
like I had mentioned earlier there were
times where we were changing the sequel
views because of instability in our
upstream data we ended up spending hours
on this right but when we when we got
the views correct sorry when we got the
views correct instead in pandas code we
could just look at the output data and
say this I know is correct and we start
writing code against it we actually
built on top of that so we have all
these custom queries that come in
sometimes if I didn't have the right
view in place I could spend hours
writing another view in sequel to try to
get it right whereas instead in pandas
code which is merely a language that I
just understand
than sequel in pandas code I had that
function in a matter of mere minutes
right so think about saving hours of a
day going to get the data that you
actually need because you had great
confidence and great expectations
perfect expectations about the data that
you were handling okay now of course the
way to have absolutely perfect
expectations is to never have the schema
change under you all right so fight back
against the data analyst who changes the
capitalization of your column names okay
so we we took like a ten-minute time me
and my intern in Basel we pair coded
remotely I wrote the function in a
notebook sharing screen and we're and
and at the end of it it was actually not
me who realized that we might have taken
hours it was him because he he had been
wrestling with views for a long time and
he at one point said wow we might have
taken the whole afternoon to just get
this correct and here we are with the
chart in ten minutes
so go figure tests were great Knicks
really accelerated the workflow okay so
I'm gonna wrap up with a few points on
how to build out the regular practice of
testing especially if you're in a data
science team that doesn't have existing
an existing culture for it the first one
is borrowed from Novartis is latest
millennial craze of being hashtag
unbossed okay go ask our go watch some
videos on YouTube about like our CEO
talking about unbossed and you know
culture and all of that but I really
believe in this one because I do that
with my boss a lot when being on boss
really just means take the initiative so
if you don't want to if you don't want
to so so if you if you don't want the
the pushback and you don't want have to
ask permission but ask ask for
forgiveness that's really what it's all
about okay so go out and build stuff
that make it easy for yourself as well
as for others to write you know these
tests go
push your DevOps team every says every
every
company's gonna have a slightly
different DevOps setup DevOps are
extremely crucial to getting the culture
of testing going when I mean DevOps
really all I'm talking about is the
continuous integration systems that
automatically test your project code
base on every single commit you want
that in place you don't want like humans
hitting make tests in from your make
file right you want a system that just
does it so you don't even have to think
about it so go build the CI systems
knock on the door of your dev ops team
tell them you need help setting it up if
you don't know how to do it they'll
guide you through it write tests you
know learn how to do the manual testing
first and then automate all of that away
all right
which brings me on to that next next
thing you automate everything you don't
don't do auto manual testing with your
examples automate the generation of
examples don't do Jupiter notebook based
testing where you just sort of visually
inspect the output declare think
carefully if you want to build the
culture of testing you need to make
things really convenient so set up the
CI system don't allow adopt workflows
that also prevent code from being merged
untested especially if this is not your
fun project at work but something that
someone is going to depend on okay
finally building credibility is
important because I know there is going
to be the human factor I was talking
with Sean this afternoon about like what
how hard is it to change things right in
the culture of change humans are like
the biggest barrier it's not tech it's
it's humans so you need to build the
credibility with others that say
changing up a little bit the way that we
do our science is going to have much
greater benefits even if they are
invisible at the moment they are going
to have dividends paid off way down the
road with engineering teams being happy
to work with data science teams if
that's the set up at your firm with your
future self being able to accelerate
your work later on because you invested
in a lot of automation and testing so
build a credibility
if you notice a benefit right to your
DevOps team a blog post an internal blog
post or an email or whatever
DevOps teams have a hard job and they
get bashed quite often at least a
neighbor if they some some system fails
so they're always happy to hear of
success stories and if it comes left
comes from left field in a team that
isn't expected to use DevOps tooling but
is now that that adds to the joy of
their work and finally deliver talks
about testing ok cool
so some conclusions you depend on data
or code write tests for it it these
these three lines sort of remind me of
some Beyonce song so it will pass on
that okay some resources that are
available on the slide if you want to
get started and finally have happy
testing thank you very much
we have some time for some questions so
you mentioned that testing might take a
little bit of benefits yep but in a lot
of research contests at the very front
what you're doing is essentially
prototyping Daffy dined out of your ten
implementations you might have thrown
away yep right only two out of ten do I
test and it's purely for the practice of
getting familiar with a tooling and not
over investing so I totally agree with
like the time investment is not
something you want to waste right so the
usual the at least for myself the the
usual decision point for writing a
function and therefore a test is I've
copied and pasted that phone that block
of code more than once right and so then
once I know oh crap I'm going to depend
on this block of code that's when I
actually go and write a test just for
that little piece of code the full
pipeline where I'm prototyping like I
actually don't write tests for the full
analysis pipeline until I know an
engineer is going to use it
yes it says so the question is am i a
good person if my code is not 100%
tested yes you have intrinsic value as a
human being
[Laughter]
on a more serious note even the packages
that I've built that our open source are
not 100% testers it's really hard to do
testing at a confidence level of a
hundred percent statisticians please
pardon the pun so it is much easier of
course to be able to say well okay I'll
test to the extent that I can and as
soon as I catch a bug we'll write a test
that makes it will modify the function
and write a test that explicitly brings
out that bug and makes sure that we
don't ever encounter that bug anymore
so that has happened at least three or
four times in the protein engineering
project that I'm working working on
anything else where the assumptions
might not be clear
that you're testing 100% of what the
model okay so the question here is code
is easy to measure in terms of coverage
even though example coverage may not be
a hundred percent lines of code coverage
can be a hundred percent how do we do
that for data and for that I'm going to
ask for help from Kyle I'm wondering if
you have any ideas on this because I
haven't thought deeply about this okay
okay so how would you measure data
coverage yeah okay no problem
I'm sure it's a great discussion
question afterwards okay okay
okie Dokes do you have a preview of like
what but what ideas have at least been
thrown out okay no worries alright
thanks a lot though thanks for the help
I had a question up front and then back
there and then there yes yes yes and so
if the view itself is complicated we do
try to modularize what we're doing and
declare in our comments of the docstring
of the function that creates like the
intermediate views we declare where we
intend this function like the output of
this function to be used and we actually
I have found myself explicitly naming
this output is expected to be used in
that next function so and it just
provides the text contextual link
between those functions now yes yes it
is absolutely that I don't know how to
do this but I've never been able to
successfully comment and document my
sequel views when they live all on the
server and not in my codebase right and
that makes it a lot more difficult to
maintain okay that another question
behind
okay so frameworks for testing model
outputs model outputs look like data so
if your model output function is wrapped
in such a way that you return a panda's
data frame you can use great
expectations for this for this purpose
if you don't you can use I guess PI test
machinery to at least do some first pass
testing in place so yeah I'm probably
you're probably thinking about oh the
model does it predict an unreasonably
high number for example given some
certain data or some impossibly low
number that sort of thing right yeah
that that's what I would approach how to
approach it yes
check stock check to the tests aha uh
okay so actually I'm ah okay okay here
yes so yes um checking data well okay so
with so the comment was that we can use
hypothesis style tests to test our data
I'm not a hundred percent sure how how
to do it on the spot but it sounds
plausible to me it yeah it sounds
plausible but I'm not sure how to how to
how how I would like live code it in
this moment
I with that I've certainly learned a lot
I'm certainly also guilty of being lazy
we all have our moments but I appreciate
that
Eric took the time to share some of his
thoughts on testing especially the data
science space yeah and so with that lets
thank you again for a great talk thanks
a lot
Thanks